Bitte schön. Okay.
Mein Name ist Gündus, ich bin die Assistenzaristin hier auf Node Aufnahme
und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Okay, zuerst brauche ich ein paar persönliche Daten.
Die muss ich in Ihrer Arktaschreiben.
Ja.
Und ja, wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Klaus Haskenhof.
Klaus, soll ich Buch stabilen?
Ja, bitte.
Klaus, K, L, A, U, S, Klaus.
Und der Nachname ist Haskenhof.
Schreibt sich H, A, S, K, E, N, H, U, F, F, 2 mal F.
Alles klar, Herr Haskenhof.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 46 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 19. Juli 1975.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
1,84 m.
4,80 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
82 kg.
Okay, alles gut.
Ja, Herr Haskenhof, was für Beschwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Ja, ich habe so seit ungefähr 3 Tagen, habe ich heftige Schmerzen im Rücken
und im linken Bein.
Seit 3 Tagen haben Sie das.
Ist das plötzlich oder langsam begonnen?
Nee, ziemlich plötzlich.
Kam plötzlich.
Okay.
Ist in der Ruhe aufgeschätzt oder bei Belastung?
Ja, ich musste einen schweren Sack mit Blumen Erde tragen.
Den musste ich hochheben und dann habe ich mich gedreht und dabei ist mir das in den Rücken gefahren.
Sie haben aber so etwas höhere nicht?
Ja, ich habe immer mal etwas Rückenschmerzen in den letzten Monaten,
aber das habe ich auf meinen Beruf zurückgeführt.
Aber solche Schmerzen, die auch ins Bein reingehen, hatte ich vorher noch nie?
Ja, sie haben auch im linken Bein Schmerzen.
Ja.
Okay, es ist Schaden in den linken Bein aus oder sie haben auch...
Das geht runter bis in den Fuß, in die Seite unten an den Knöchel.
Okay.
Können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Ist das brennend, zierhend?
Was für Schmerzen ist das?
Es ist mehr so brennend.
Aber auch dann ist es so ein bisschen auf der Haut, so ein bisschen wie pelzig.
Wenn man so drüber führt...
Wie holen, meinen Sie? Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Wie kribbeln?
Ich habe immer kribbeln und brennend.
Es kribbelt an der Haut da und es brennt.
Aber wenn ich über die Haut drüber fahre mit dem Finger,
fühlt sich das etwas pelzig an so.
Ich spüre das nicht so gut auf der Haut wie auf sonst auf der Haut.
Ja, ist gut.
Diese kribbeln und Störungen,
verspüren Sie wo genau?
Im linken Bein?
Ja, so am Unterschenkel, hier auf der Außenseite am Unterschenkel.
Außenseite, okay.
Also in der Wade und dann bis in den Knöchel und
ja, so bis in den Außenfuß.
Okay.
Hat sich Ihre Rückenschmerzen mit Bewegung verschlechtert?
Ja, Bewegung ist nicht gut.
Auch wenn ich mal husten muss, das ist auch schlimmer.
Ja.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Ihrer...
Wasserlassen zu halten?
Wie sagt man das?
Ja, Wasserlassen und Stuhlgang?
Ja, ich meine, unwillig wasserlassen.
unwillkürlich.
Ja.
Nein, ich kann, das geht.
Wasserlassen und Stuhlgang ist kein Problem.
Das geht.
Sie haben aber keine Unfall gehabt.
Nein, kein Unfall.
Aber ich habe keine Schwere,
und beim Begen hatten Sie...
Ein schwerer Sack hochheben, der Sack ist ungefähr 30 Kilo.
Und das muss ich oft machen bei der Arbeit.
Was machen Sie denn vom Beruf?
Ich bin im Gartenbau.
Ich bin im Garten- und Landschaftsbau.
Ich muss Wege pflastern und Bäume fällen.
Ich muss schwer tragen.
Können Sie Ihre Beine gut bewegen?
Ja, ich kann sie bewegen.
Aber ich merke, wenn ich so treppen steige,
das fällt mir schwer.
Also gerade treppen runter,
und ich habe nicht so viel Kraft.
Ich habe den eindrücklich Knick so weg.
Alles klar.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Scala
von 1 bis 10, wobei ein sehr leichten Schmerz
und sehr starken Schmerz entspricht?
Sie haben schon gesagt,
dass Sie solche Schmerzen beim Rücken schon gesprüft haben.
Aber das ist, ich denke, etwas erheftiger.
Ich würde sagen 1 bis 10, da würde ich sagen 8.
Haben Sie auch Kältegefühl in Ihrer Beine?
Nein, Kältegefühl.
Es kribbelt und brennt.
Nein, kältegefühl nicht.
Haben Sie etwas Ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Ja, noch etwas Ungewöhnliches.
Ich habe noch etwas Ungewöhnliches bemerkt.
Nein, sonst nichts Besonderes.
Okay.
Wie fühlen Sie sich denn sonst körperlich?
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Fieber gehabt?
Schüttefrost oder Nachts Schweiß?
Nein, ich habe mich sonst immer ganz gesund gefühlt.
Ich konnte auch immer arbeiten.
Ich bin nicht krank gewesen.
Nein, das letzte Mal war ich, glaube ich, krank.
Ich konnte nicht arbeiten vor zwei Jahren.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Angewicht verloren?
Nein.
Nein, mein Gewicht habe ich immer so.
Zwischen 80 und 84 kg.
Das ist aber immer schon seit Jahren schon so in dem Bereich.
Wie ist es beim Schlagzeug?
Wie ist es beim Schlafen?
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Einschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Nein, ich kann super gut schlafen.
Morgen bin der Wecker Scheld.
Um halb sechs muss ich aufstehen.
Dann möchte ich immer noch weiter schlafen.
Aber ich kann gut schlafen.
Ja.
Ich habe schon gefragt, ob Sie Ihre Gewische mit dem Wasser lassen.
Ich möchte noch wissen, ob Sie Ihre Gewische mit dem Stuhlgang haben.
Nein.
Alles klar.
Sie haben auch erwähnt, dass Sie vor zwei Jahren krank waren.
Ich denke, Sie haben keine chronische Erkrankung.
Vor zwei Jahren war ich mal krank.
Da war eine Grippe.
Das war eine Grippe.
Da war nichts.
Ich war zehn Tage krank.
Ich war immer alles gut.
Bei Ihnen war es keine Erkrankung.
Keine Erkrankung.
Ich nehme Medikamente ein.
Gegen hohen Blutdruck.
Sie haben Bluthochdruck.
Seit fünf Jahren nehme ich die Tabletten ein.
Ich habe die Tabletten ein.
Ich habe hier ein Zettel.
Das steht drauf.
Die Tablette.
Eine Tablette morgens.
Und dann steht hier noch Ramie Bril.
Eine Tablette abends.
morgens und eine Tablette abends. Wurden sie dann schon mal operiert? Ja, das ist aber schon lange her.
Als Kind wurde ich an den Mandeln operiert. Da war ich glaube ich sieben Jahre alt. Und dann wurde
ich operiert am Blinddarm. Da war ich 18 und dann wurde ich noch mal operiert am rechten Fuß,
am Sprunggelenk hatte ich eine Bruch durch Fußball spielen. Da war ich 21. Ich habe
gar nicht gut verstanden. Hatten Sie irgendwelche ihre Knochen gebrochen oder? Ja, der Knochen war
gebrochen am Knöchel, am Sprunggelenk glaube ich heißt das. Rechts am rechten Fuß und das wurde
operiert. Da war ich 21. Das war beim Fußballspielen passiert. Als Medikamente nehmen Sie Bysoprolol und
Jomipil. Außer dieser nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein, keiner. Ist bei Ihnen allergin bekannt?
Nein, allergin habe ich nicht. Sind Sie regelmäßig geimpft auch gegen Corona? Ja, habe ich jetzt die
dritte Impfung gemacht, diese Booster Impfung und sonst habe ich auch alle Impfungen. Ich gehe
auch zur Vorsorgeuntersuchung zum Hausarzt und wer hat gesagt, ich brauche nicht, im Augenblick
nicht geimpft werden. Ist alles in Ordnung. Okay, jetzt möchte ich nach Ihrer Lebensgewohnheit
fragen. Zum Beispiel rauchen Sie, trinken Sie Alkohol, eventuell auch Drogen? Also Drogen
nehme ich nicht. Alkohol trinke ich abends in eine Flasche Bier, so halber Liter, 0,5 eine,
aber nicht mehr. Täglich Arbeit, oder? Eigentlich jeden Tag. Rauchen tu ich schon seit 30 Jahren,
auch ich so 20 Zigaretten, also eine Packung am Tag. Seit 30 Jahren haben Sie das? Ja, seit 30 Jahren.
Okay. Ist bei Ihrer Familie, bei Ihrer Nährung und Zerwand schafft ein wichtiger Erkrankung bekannt.
Was verstehen Sie unter wichtige Erkrankungen? Ich meine chronische Erkrankungen zum Beispiel
Bluthochdruck, Blutsuckerkrankheit oder irgendwelche Krebserkrankungen. Also Krebserkrankungen
nicht. Meine Eltern, die haben beide etwas Alterszucker, die sind beide 70 Jahre alt und der Vater hat
Alterszucker und etwas hohen Blutdruck auch und die Mutter hat Alterszucker und Atrose,
Atrose an den Fingern, aber kein richtiges Rheuma. Alterszucker haben Sie gesagt? Ja, der Arzt
sagt Ihnen immer, Sie hätten Alterszucker. Also die haben den Zucker auch jetzt erst seit wenigen
Jahren im Alter gekriegt und die nehmen beide eine Zuckertablette, glaube ich, ein, aber das
ist glaube ich ganz gut so, sind die Werte ganz gut. Sie haben aber erhöhte Zuckerwerte,
oder? Die haben die Eltern, ja. Ja, ich meine die Eltern, ja. Okay, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie als
Gardnerbau arbeiten. Ja. Ich möchte auch wissen, ob Sie verheiratet sind. Ja, ich bin verheiratet. Wir
haben zwei Kinder, die Kinder sind 16 und 18 Jahre alt, die sind gesund. Sie leben mit ihrer Familie
zusammen. Ja, ja. Okay, ich bin, ich habe alle Fragen meiner Seite gestellt. Und was, was, was
kann das sein? Was denken Sie, was ich haben kann? Also Herr Haskenhof, ich habe noch keine
konkrete Diagnose gestellt, aber ich gehe davon aus, dass Sie ein Problem mit Ihrer Bandscheibe haben,
mit, mit Ihrer Muskulatur. Okay. Aber um eine genaue Aussage machen zu können, möchte ich Sie gerne
körperlich untersuchen. Ja. Und ich möchte noch eine MRT-Untersuchung machen, Kenspien. Okay.
Untersuchung ja. Danach können wir weiter spägen. Okay. Bin ich mit einverstanden. Alles klar.
Brauchen Sie noch Fragen an mich? Danke, nein im Augenblick nicht. Brauchen Sie fünf Minuten zum
bleiben. Bitte. Bis gleich. Bis gleich. Okay. Ja. Guten Tag. Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt. Ich habe eine neue
Aufnahme. In der Notaufnahme die möchte ich Ihnen gerne vorstellen. Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Hab ich. Okay. Herr Klaus Haskenhof, 48 Jahre alte, alt, neun, ist neun Zentren, Juli 1975 geboren. Er ist
1 Meter 84 Zentimeter groß und wiegt derzeit 82 Kilo. Der Patient stellte sich wegen der plötzlich
beginnenden seit drei Tagen bestehende heftige Schmerzen im Lücken und im linken Bein bei uns vor. Er gab
an, dass die Schmerzen brennend sind, eine Ausstrahlung im ganzen linken Bein bis hin zum Fuß von vorhanden.
Die Schmerzintenz dazhüfte er auf 8 von 10 ein. Außerdem sagte der Patient, dass er Sensibilität
Stürmen betroffenen Beine habe. Wo sind die Sensibilität Stürmen? Es ist im linken Außenseiter des
linken Beins. Ja, linker Unterschenkel. Ja, linker, linken Unterschenkel. Gibt es eine, eine, eine Ursache
dieser Schmerzen? Ist er gestürzt oder? Ja, ich habe darüber gesprochen, aber er hat
irgendwie einen Fall verneint, aber er habe eine schwere Sage, er habe versucht, eine schwere
Sage hochzuheben und beim Brechen habe er diese Schmerzen verspürt, eigentlich. Das war die Auslöser.
Er ist ein Gardner-Bauer. Ja, ja, solche Schmerzen habe er auch. Im letzten
Zeit, das ist eine intermitierende Lumbargie eigentlich, aber das war nicht so stark.
Die Schmerzen in der früheren Zeit waren die genauso stark und hatten die auch eine
Ausstrahlung oder war das eine rückenschmerzige? Die war ohne Ausstrahlung und ohne Sensibilität
Stimmung. Er berichtete nur rückenschmerzen. Okay. Berichtet der Patient über Paresen? Genau, beim
Treppelsteigen bemerkte er am linken Fußbereich. Ja, also beim Flexiworn. Über eine Schwäche, über
eine Schwäche im Bein oder auch über, hat er auch Paresen. Hat er Paresen in der Blasenmuskulatur,
hat Erlähmungserscheinungen dort? Ach so, ja, ich bin mir nicht sicher. Aber Sie haben mich gefragt,
haben Sie Beschwerden beim Wasserlassen? Ja. Ja, das habe ich. Ich habe keine Beschwerden. Also die
Frage nach eventuell neurologischen Ausfallsfinkter, Glasensfinkter oder Schließmuskelstuhlgang,
sind verneint worden. Also da gibt es keine neurologischen Ausfälle. Genau. Aber er habe
Kribben der Beine auch? Aber keine Störung des Wasserlassens. Er kann den Urin halten. Ja.
Hat keine Inkontinenz, weder in der Blase noch im Rektum. Keine Stuhlinkoninenz. Gut. Okay.
Hat der Patient Schmerzmittel gebraucht? Wir haben darüber nicht gesprochen, ob er schon mal
Schmerzmittel eingenommen hat oder nicht. Ich muss mal fragen, aber er betet keine Schmerzmittel.
Hat der Patient sonst chronische Erkrankungen? Bei ihm, Artilielle Lipatonie bekannt, seit fünf
Jahren. Dagegen nehme er Bsopolol fünf Milligramm einmal morgens und Jamipril fünf Milligramm einmal
morgens und einmal abends. Ja gut. Gibt es sonst Auffälligkeiten in der Vorgeschichte,
Risikofaktoren? Für einen frische Herr Nibancheim Vorfall. Ein eigener Risikofaktor ist Arbeit. Er ist
Gardnerbauer vom Beruf. Das ist sicherlich ein Risikofaktor. Hat der Patient Voroperationen?
Ja, mit sieben Jahren, lebensjahr, wurde eine Tonsillektomie durchgeführt und mit 18
Ependeptimi. Er habe gesagt, auch wegen einer Unfall des Spungsgelenk würde eine Ostiastentese
durchgetragen. Wie alt war der Patient da? Ich muss das mal auch fragen. Das war beim Kindheit,
aber mit 21 Jahren. Ein Fußballspiel. Ja. Okay. Gut. Was haben Sie für eine Verdachtdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Diskuspolapsus. Ja. Welchen Bereich würden Sie erwarten bei dieser
Ausstrahlung seitlicher Unterschenkel? Ja, L4, L5 oder? L5. Ja. Kann man denken. Ja. Die Verdachtdiagnose
kann man pädifere Nähren schaden, Degenerative Veranderung oder herpes Zoster? Ja, herpes Zoster
gut. Kann oft auch noch im Frühstadium sein ohne Hauteffluoreszenzen. Haben wir immer wieder
schon erlebt, dass Patienten erst auf Rücken und Bandscheibe behandelt werden beim
Autopäden. Und dann kommen plötzlich die Hauteffluoreszenzen und dann ist die Diagnose eines
herpes Zoster da. Der ist natürlich anders behandelt werden muss als ein Bandscheibenvorfall. Das ist
klar. Was spricht denn, aber für einen Bandscheibenvorfall spricht ja eher dieses... An am Nese. Nese des
Hebens, des Drehens vielleicht, dass das ein plötzlicher Schmerz war. Das spricht nicht
unbedingt für ein herpes Zoster, aber in die Differenzialdiagnose sollte man das mit einbeziehen.
Gibt es einen Hinweis für eine PAVK? Das war eigentlich... Ich muss auch beiderkörperlich
untersuchen auf der Beine, ob irgendwelche Hautveranderungen, Haurausfall gibt oder nicht. Aber
er belichtete nicht bei Belastung irgendwelchen Schmerzen eigentlich. Er hat Bewegungseinschenkung,
kann nicht bewegen, aber das fängt nicht nach Laufen. Okay, okay, spricht nicht dafür. Er hat eine
Schwäche im Bein, sicherlich eine gewisse Kraftminderung wahrscheinlich. Sie haben beschrieben,
beim Treppensteigen, das spricht ja eher auch für eine Bandscheibenproblematik als für eine PAVK.
Gut, Risikofaktoren sonst, braucht er? Für PAVK, ja, er hat Nikotinkonsum 30-Payout, er
hat Bluthochdruck, habe keine familiärer Disposition. Gut, ich füge jetzt die Arbeitsdiagnose,
Verdachtdiagnose, Discos Prolapse im Segment vielleicht L5, vielleicht auch S1, L4 ist glaube
ich ein bisschen höher, aber mal gucken. Und differenzial diagnostisch sicherlich kann ein
Herbst Zoster mit reinspielen oder eventuell eine PAVK. Was spricht gegen ein Pseudoradikuläres
Syndrome? Es gibt ja auch einen Pseudoradikulären Schmerz ins Bein, also mit einer rein Irritation
vielleicht des Nerven. Wir machen jetzt eine kleine Fachprüfung. Wahrscheinlich spricht dagegen,
dass er eine neurologische Symptomatik hat, also zum Beispiel, dass die Kraftminderung da ist,
nach dem Bein, dass er nicht gut Treppen steigen kann, dass er das spürt, dass er da nicht viel
Kraft im Bein hat. Das ist glaube ich beim pseudoradikulären Syndrome eher so nicht der Fall.
Ich denke die Arbeitsdiagnose ist so, was machen Sie jetzt weiter,
in weiteren diagnostischen Schritten? Also wenn wir Discos Prolapse bestätigen,
es hängt davon ab, welche Stufe es hat. Wir haben konservative Therapie mit dem konservative
Therapie anfangen, Medikamentos. Er hat Schmerzen, Schmerztherapie und
anti-inflammatorische Therapie, auch Physiotherapie. Okay. Und ich meinte zuerst, da haben Sie ja
vorhin schon gesagt, zuerst die körperliche Untersuchung mit Schwerpunkt neurologische
Untersuchung, Reflexe, Pulse, Lautinspektionen, gegebenenfalls Bildgebung, kommt ins Spiel MRT
oder ein CT, je nachdem. Und dann entscheidet, ist es etwas konservativ zu behandeln,
oder eben operativ. Der Patient hat keine akute Symptomatik, die eine Intervention notwendig
macht wie eine Blasen- und Mastarmproblematik. Er hat keine Hinkonnenz. Insofern können wir
jetzt erst mal mit einer ausreichenden Schmerztherapie auch dem Patienten vielleicht dann auch helfen.
Ja, ich finde, das haben Sie sehr gut und sehr ruhig gemacht und die Anamnese auch systematisch
gut erhoben. Und das war auch sehr gut verständlich. Nachher bei der Schilderung beim Oberarzt,
dann versuchen Sie mal nicht die Hand vor den Mund zu nehmen, das haben Sie häufig dann
gemacht. Das ist einfach weghalten die Hand. Aber gut ist, Sie haben die Fachausdrücke dann
eingesetzt. Tonsylektromie, Apendectromie, Ostiosynthese, das wird ja gewünscht, dass Sie da
umschalten von der Patientensprache in die Klinische Sprache und ich denke, das ist Ihnen gut
und wenn haben Sie Prüfung am 16. Mai und wo haben Sie die Prüfung in Düsseldorf?